I do have a voicemail number that you
can call any time of day two one nine to
david p is the number let's take a
listen to this voicemail hey David uh
you know you always talk about on your
show about obesity and Houston epidemic
in America so do you think that maybe
food advertisers might be responsible
for some of it simply because of the
deceptive nature of food advertising how
you know burgers from mcdonald's are
uncooked only cooked on the outside and
you know use blow torches to melt the
cheese on the edges make everything look
super duper nice when in reality they're
just serving you crap quite literally
which is why people are being obese what
are you thoughts on this yeah I mean the
thing is obviously advertising has a
role to play in glorifying unhealthy
foods etc but they have food advertising
in other countries as well I know
different countries regulated in
slightly different ways so there's
probably some role that food advertising
is playing depicting people with these
huge sodas makes it seem like a
reasonable thing to drink a 32 or 64
ounce soda when it really isn't but it
is not all that is to blame because
other countries with far lower obesity
rates also have food advertising on the
bonus show today I'm going to talk about
a story that speculates about sabotage
or as William Shatner says it's sabotage
involving SpaceX and a space exploration
we will talk about that I've also got a
really really funny story involving a
road rage incident I was involved in and
was able to i think really productively
defuse david pakman.com slash membership
is how you sign up for the bonus show
and today's bonus show is an excellent
one